Well, hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
We go for your questions. We get some answers.
Reminder to everybody to look at the member site to see the announcements,
and you can self-schedule calls,
and follow up calls, or anything to go already.
I'm sorry, I didn't like that.
Sure.
You do that.
Takes life a little easier.
Okay, first question. After a recent cheap swamp test,
you suggested two tablespoons per day of the filing nine by one.
Since I can't afford $55 a week for one supplement,
because that supplement is about $55,
and two tablespoons will probably be consumed in about a week.
Should I just skip it or do whatever I can afford?
It was a good question for everybody.
Like, what if I can't afford to continue
at the dosage that you asked me to continue at?
What should I do?
Well, there's really two ways to do it.
You could drop down into a smaller dose per day,
or you could take the recommended,
just a couple days a week.
So if you could afford my dollars a month for that supplement,
by taking it maybe two days a week,
maybe taking it on Sunday,
that's one way to do it.
So you're getting a higher dose that's affected,
affecting the tissue over those two days.
That's one way to take it.
So it depends on the supplements.
Now, Thailand died by,
what is the supplement to help dislodge bad estrogens
from the estrogen receptor on the cancer cell?
It's self cancer membrane,
some membrane.
So in this case,
I would suggest you take a lower dosage per day.
So with this supplement,
you better have a lower dosage per day.
So you have some residual dosage in your tissues on a daily basis.
But other supplements,
it may be better to,
that did create a video on pulsing supplements.
But in this case, I'd say,
lower dose per day would be better.
After a cheap swap,
you recommended turkey tail complete.
Do you prefer this over the host defense turkey tail?
I included my host defense supplement for you to test.
Does the fact that you recommended the center one,
be that the host defense did not test as well for me?
That's correct.
So you test supplements,
I test them different ones.
And with the turkey tail complete,
just tested better for you.
Now, in this case,
in a case like this,
let's say this person,
I don't know that this is true,
but let's say they have a whole bunch of host defense turkey tail in their cupboard.
I would certainly not want you to waste that.
So unless the person,
the caveat would be unless the person is in dire straits,
health wise,
and they're doing very poorly in the turkey tail.
And one brand supplement tests much better than the other brand.
Then by all means,
just make the switch.
But if you're doing fairly well,
and you're not in that case scenario,
and you have access of the other brand,
still at home,
I would use that up before you change.
But finish, finish that up and then change the turkey tail complete.
After that, after you have finished up the,
you have a brand that you have in excess of home.
So yes, whatever I make a recommendation for you,
it's because they're particular brand testing better.
What I'm supposed to be dairy free,
can I still eat raw dairy?
And the answer is,
no, you can't.
So this is a question from somebody who has cancer, right?
And if dairy is driving your cancer,
then it doesn't make any difference.
If it's pasteurized, if it's homogenized,
if it's not pasteurized and homogenized.
It doesn't also make a difference,
whether it's cow dairy or goat dairy or sheep dairy.
So all of those are,
have the capability of driving cancer
and stimulating growth of cancer.
So,
but we tested you to be dairy free.
We test all those dairies.
So now this is different.
This would be a different question.
If the person was asking because they did,
they don't have cancer and it's not because the dairy is driving the cancer.
But is,
if they have a dairy allergy.
So if the person did,
let's say,
food sensitivity test,
let's say they did a,
a Syrix array for testing for cross-reactions to go to the array 10.
These are testing for KC.
And the reason why I like the Syrix is it does differentiate between different types of dairy.
And it differentiates the,
the form of dairy,
meaning it might be cow's milk is positive,
but cheese you can eat.
So some people that have a KC sensitivity,
that's a totally different ball of wax,
and they may not react to a certain type of cheese,
but they react to another type of cheese or they react to milk itself.
For instance,
I know people who could eat goats,
cheese,
we're talking about cancer patients,
we're talking about people with a sensitivity.
I can eat goats,
cheese,
but they can't eat cow's cheese.
It's because the KC is slightly changed,
differentiated with the protein itself is different between sources
and the protein can be different,
and changed and altered when in the cooking process.
But that has to do with sensitivity,
that has to do with the presence of antibodies to a protein or a peptide,
or should have a protein.
So when we talk about cancer,
and let's drive the answer,
and I recommend the dairy free.
It doesn't make any difference in raw dairy,
it doesn't make any difference with type of dairy,
dairy goats, dairy cows, dairy,
and it's like caveat to those who sometimes ask this question,
are eggs dairy don't talk about dairy is coming out of the butter of the animal.
So,
hopefully they're unable to explain it.
Why is gluten bad for your brain?
So,
from a cancer standpoint,
gluten is almost never a driver of cancer.
However, gluten can be a driver of inflammation.
So back to the antibody answer of the question before,
if I have antibodies to the protein in gluten,
which is gliadin, or a peptide medium portion
of the gliadin protein, every time I eat protein,
I am gonna cause inflammation first in the gut
and then I'll elsewhere in the body.
So gluten has an in your intestinal tract,
you have gluteal morphine receptors
that fire back to the brain.
You also have caseal morphine receptors
that fire back to the right brain,
that to do a dairy, caseeed is the protein of dairy.
The added is the protein of gluten.
So if you have antibodies to gluten or caseeed,
you will fire back into the brain
to your cause of inflammatory process in the brain.
That's why gluten and dairy can be bad for your brain
because it can cause that inflammation in the brain.
For any of my videos, I've always said
inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of the brain
because of these connections.
So if you have inflammation in the brain,
then that causes brain fog, that causes all sorts of problems.
Now a person who has had head trauma,
let's say they've had post-concussive syndrome,
let's say they've had Lyme disease
on the process of blood-brain variant.
Let's say they had vaccine injury
that has crossed the blood-brain variant.
Let's say they had brain cancer or a tumor.
So they already had some other source of damage
to the brain slash inflammation of the brain.
Slash microglial cell primed slash antibodies
to neural tissue for the brain of a motor neuron system.
Any of those things are present or have been present
to the past eating anything that could be causing inflammation
in the gut, not even gluten or dairy,
or say anything else that you may have antibodies
against your causing inflammation of the gut,
you can cause inflammation of the brain as well.
That's why anybody that has those things
really should do a Cyrex 10, really a 3x Cyrex array,
3x Cyrex array, 4 Cyrex array, 10 would be good.
So if you're having serious,
and this goes for even people who have had a lot of chemo,
they have chemo-brains
cause that has damaged the blood-brain barrier chemo
being an oxidizing agent can damage the blood-brain barrier
which is just a single cell protection
around the blood vessels of the brain
or by the astrocytes, that can become damaged
by all sorts of toxins and chemicals,
including chemotherapy,
and then things cross that lack of barrier
and get into the brain and cause inflammation of the brain,
damage cells, the most commonly damaged cells
in the brain are these microglial cells
and they can become damaged, was called primed
and those can be just a source of constant inflammation.
And again, worst case scenario is that you end up
developing antibodies against neural tissue, brain tissue.
And then you have a problem
because you're basically set up for, you know,
you have a basically an autoimmune disease at the brain
and you're set up for a destruction of neural tissue
whatever you have antibodies against.
So every time you eat anything that's gonna cause inflammation
or you're exposed to things
or you're gonna cause inflammation
or you have inflammation even from exposure to a virus
or you get a cold, you're gonna damage that
which you have antibodies against first
and if it's to neural tissue, you're gonna have issues.
So gluten can be a bad player,
but a lot of foods can be a bad player
but so you want to test for those.
That's why you would test for foods
or I want to buy a deal with that for my breast cancer
because you don't want other forms of inflammation
that take, you know, energy you could say
away from your immune system that you're trying
to kill this cancer.
So it can be wise to test for those.
That's why I give you guys access to the autoimmune course.
Well, I don't have autoimmune disease.
I have cancer, I'm trying to deal with that.
Yeah, so still you have clomorbidities
that decrease your body's ability
to be able to kill cancer.
So the more you can learn about how to
find those triggers and deal with those
and remember my book, I talk about most people with cancer
also have a clomorbidity of autoimmune disease.
So understanding that can be very helpful
in your cause to come back, you know, cancer as well.
So don't neglect that.
What are the dangers of using a stat drug
to lower cholesterol, especially with the cancer
diagnosis?
The stat drugs do lower cholesterol.
You can't argue with that.
However, they also do all sorts of damage
to deliver itself.
And there are long-term studies,
and I didn't pull any of them up,
but there are long-term studies showing that, you know,
people taking a stat into lower cholesterol
really don't have any better outcomes
as far as reducing coronary artery disease
or having, you know, any type of myocardial infarction.
So just because you can lower,
just because you can alter a blood value with a drug,
doesn't mean that you leave a patient any healthy.
So I'll say it again, just because you could use a drug
to change the value of a blood marker,
to put it back into more normal range,
doesn't mean that you've actually made a healthier patient.
So be careful about that.
It's just like men with prostate cancer,
they have an elevated PSA.
You go on energy deprivation therapy.
I'll guarantee you that at least for a couple of years,
your PSA is gonna be a normal range.
But don't be fool to think that that had sold your problem
and your cancer is gone.
You've just lowered the PSA marker artificially
by taking a medication you've necessarily reduced
that person's chance of metastasis
or, you know, increased their life expectancy.
I mean, if you're really just solely concerned
about getting a blood marker back in normal levels,
just crossing out on your blood test
and just write a normal level in there.
It's that, you know, makes you feel better.
What are you talking about?
That's absolutely getting out of it, right?
Well, that's kind of what we're doing
by just using medication to get the marker back
into lower level, and it's far less destructive
because you cross it out on your blood test.
Doesn't have any side effects.
But I'd rather not have you do either one of those things.
The smarter thing to do is try to figure out why.
Now, sometimes cholesterol as a marker is difficult
because some people could have a elevated cholesterol
that is hereditary.
You could have hereditary factors
that you have hyper-cholesterolemia
and that you can't really do anything to lower it.
Some people have a perfect diet
or doing everything perfect
and they still have elevated cholesterol.
Maybe that's just normal for them.
You know, understand values.
It's like the normal temperature is 98.6.
Well, some people's normal temperature is 96.6
and some people's normal temperature is 99.6.
That normal temperature is just, you know,
the average human race that has been tested.
So sometimes you can do everything right
and you can't get your certain levels back into normal.
Is that increasing your risk for different things maybe?
But I don't see that using a medication
that could have other side effects
is the smart thing to do.
Now, is there a greater risk with a stat growing
with a cancer patient?
Now, I don't think there's any greater risk
with a stat growing with a cancer patient
unless they also have liver cancer.
But I haven't seen any data on that.
Why is iodine not a good idea for someone
with breast cancer?
I do not have a thyroid cancer.
I take compounded thyroid medication
and told there's a link between thyroid cancer and breast cancer.
Well, iodine can be a good thing for breast cancer
used acutely.
So I don't think that breast cancer patient
should be on iodine long term.
The problem with iodine and the thyroid
is the thyroid needs iodine in order to make T3s.
So that's a necessary component.
But when we take exogenous iodine in a supplement,
it's basically taking a hyperdose of iodine.
You're really stimulating a lot of attraction
to the thyroid gland by the immune system.
And the chance of you developing an autoimmune thyroid,
if you're taking iodine long term,
the chance of you developing Hashimoto or Graves disease
is almost 100%.
That's why I'm not a fan of taking iodine long term.
So if somebody just finds out they have breast cancer
and they're going to take iodine for three months,
that's fine, especially if it tests fine for them.
But if they're going to take iodine for a couple of years,
the chance of them ended up developing Hashimoto's
even prior to any hypothyroidism, primary hypothyroidism,
is very, very high.
So that's why I'm not a fan of iodine.
I am a fan of iodine in a acute situation.
So let's say you have acute breast cancer
or even acute radiation exposure
can protect the thyroid for a very short period of time.
But you have to be careful with iodine.
You want to take a full-based iodine,
a kelp-based iodine if you're going to take it
and not long-term, this is my opinion.
This was a question from somebody called in today
with a version 6.04 software on the right commuter.
Can you just send a flash drive for a program update?
Well, the answer is yes and no.
So yes, I can if you know how to put it
into your computer correctly.
So with the version 6.04 software,
you have to create a folder in the documents folder
that says true-write frequencies
and then put your software your program into that.
If you know how to do that
and you feel really comfortable doing that,
then absolutely I can send a flash drive.
If you don't know how to do that
or you don't feel comfortable for doing that,
then I'd rather just have you send me the computer.
If you want, if you say,
I'm going to give it a try, I will trouble with that.
But if you say, I'm going to give it a try
and I'll call you if I need help,
then I do have a problem with that
because we don't have as large a staff as we used to
and it would take me longer to try to lock you
through it on your computer.
Now, on the member site and on the right frequencies course,
I put all the instructions on how to do that.
So somebody who is pretty computer savvy,
is really super easy.
But if you're like, I don't know the computer,
I'm not very good at the computer,
then I'd rather have you just send it to me,
let me do it and I'll send it back to you.
So for the person who did ask this question,
you could email me if you'd rather
if you want just a flash drive.
I was just diagnosed with pneumonia
and have been prescribed two antibiotics.
Any suggestions to counter what they are going to do
in my gut file?
Yes.
So as I've said, many, many times,
if you're taking an antibiotic,
you have to take it away with it.
Will you counter what you do to your gut biome?
Yes, you will do some culture.
You're not going to correct every damage that's done,
but there's been studies that if you take a probiotic,
and it really, the studies were interesting
because it wasn't even specific to what type of probiotic,
just taking any probiotic that you have
is going to help you tremendously.
And the studies were pretty dramatic,
it really, really helped a person
not have that issues post antibiotic use.
So whatever probiotic you have,
most people have something in their house
to start taking the probiotic.
When you take the antibiotic,
you could take it between doses as well.
The only negative is if you take too much probiotics,
you could get a little bit of running stools
or something like that,
or you could just waste your money too.
You can't solve your gut problem
by just taking a ton of probiotics,
but you can prevent the damage that an antibiotic will do,
because an antibiotic is going to kill a large percentage
of your gut biome.
What other things can you do to help install a better gut biome?
Variety of diet, variety of diet is your key.
So eating different vegetables,
a lot of people get used to,
they eat the same thing all the time.
But I know I'm speaking to the choir with you guys,
because you're good at understanding this stuff,
but maybe there's even people listening to the call
that they do eat the same thing all the time,
and their idea of eating vegetables
is eating cord with their meatloaf.
Well, cord is a blade, it's not a vegetable.
So you've got to eat a lot of different vegetables,
eating fresh things, you need some raw things,
you need a variety of different foods,
change it up your diet,
your gut biome actually changes on a weekly basis.
So the more variety of stuff that you can eat,
the better off you can be.
Today I have followed out, we can buy,
Iverbeck did over the counter from the drug stores.
I've heard a lot of good information about this drug
in cancer, can we take it and what would be the benefit?
So I haven't been hesitant to comment
about Iverbeck did in the past,
because it's a prescription medication most places.
If you just do a Google Scholar search on Iverbeck did in cancer,
you'll find that there's a number of studies
that are very positive on Iverbeck did in cancer.
So I don't see any problem with taking Iverbeck did.
The only thing I would suggest was that it is a medication,
even though it's a long-use medication,
it was initially in the market, years and years ago,
very, very, very few side effects.
I would still think that it would be best to call it.
It can, any medication can affect you in negative ways,
but it could have very positive effects.
So I know there are some people that take Iverbeck to every day,
and it's like, I just want to go.
But why?
I mean, I'm talking to people who don't even have cancer.
You know, so I don't know that I would suggest anything like that,
but I don't see, let's say if you were just trying
to protect yourself against COVID
or some other weird virus that they could have to pulse it,
might be a good thing to have it in your arsenal,
might be a good thing.
I do think that a lot of medication you can become sensitive
to meeting that if you're taking it all the time,
you're not going to get as much benefit from it.
And saving it, having it in your arsenal will take,
let's say if your cancer's doing well
and you're doing really well, then I don't know
that I would change that and take that.
Or if you don't have a virus and you're feeling well,
it might be good to have it in your arsenal
if you do need to take it.
But I think it is,
and obviously it had,
when it's a phenomenal success with COVID,
that's why they abandoned it.
I think that right question may have been, yes, it was.
I called it and I don't think my question was very clear.
I said to the cheek swab last week
with the requested new right frequencies
and wasn't sure how long I should expect to wait
for the new frequencies.
I already said to the email stating
that I could get the new frequency files
via flash drive or even download them
from an email or drop box.
If they're too large to save on the money shipping flash drive.
Yeah, we can't out one thing we can't do
and we've never been able to do is to email the frequencies.
Because of the way that a folder is,
you can't even if you put it in a folder,
I can email then you have to download it,
you have to take that
and that's really confusing.
It's even harder to do.
So, if you feel comfortable
in doing a flash drive, I'll just send the first thing.
So I don't know if you heard that answer
and you have to feel comfortable
about putting it in the opportunity.
And again, the instructions are on the member side
and right of course.
I know you've done the flash drive before
but the version 6.4 is different than the version 6.0.
So that's what I would say.
It's version 6.4, it's very different
how the program goes in to the right program.
It won't go into the main body of the program.
So in version 6.4, you have to click,
there's two more clicks you have to make.
So you open program on the version 6.4, right now,
if you just got a 6.4,
on your computer, if you open the program,
you'll see all the right programs.
But you cannot put a custom program in that folder.
You have to go over the left and click documents.
There's four little things you can click on.
One of them is documents, the second one down.
And then in documents, you'll open up that
and there will be nothing in there.
So you have to create a folder in that
called true right frequencies,
and then you put your custom folder in that.
So anybody that has a version 6.4 that I did that on,
understands that completely go,
yeah, I know, we have two more steps.
And now, if anybody started with us recently,
they don't know that at one point in time,
there was two less steps to get into their program.
They understand that they have to open up
the true right program, hit open program,
then go to documents, then go to true right frequencies,
and then go to their program.
So 6.4 is different.
So you feel comfortable doing that
on your setting with flash drive.
If you're confused at what I just said,
it is written down in the member site.
If you're like, I was totally lost,
then it'd be better to send me your computer at all,
what it is.
Either way, just think about it,
look at the instructions
and then either email, let's say,
yep, I feel good, send me the flash drive, and I'll do that.
Where do we find the clues as to how our cancer is driven?
Is it in the initial cheek swab?
Yes.
And resulting program?
No.
Well, we're talking about the right program.
No, you won't see, we're gonna close it there.
Or do we get the info from the genetic report?
No.
So depending on when you started with us,
we used to be very open about the causes.
We have causes, balancers, and then food drivers.
It's just when we got attacked by the AMA,
then we had to be careful with our terminology.
So we had to kind of take that terminology out
that what caused the cause and what was the driver's,
we had to be more careful with that terminology.
But I've had a point right now,
I just don't care, they could just throw it at you.
I just don't care anything.
So when we look at diet, so when you talk about
what is how our cancer is driven,
let's clarify that phrase.
So a cancer could be caused from something.
So anything that gets inside of a cell,
that damages the nucleus at the DNA,
the replication cycle in the cell goes into rapid replication.
That is the initial cause of the cancer.
And you could move us to find it out to help deal with that.
So it doesn't cause the same thing in another cell.
Now, understand, even if you could magically make that
all go away, let's say if the cause that got inside the cell,
that damaged the DNA, that caused it to go into rapid replication.
Let's pretend it was a Michael Thompson.
If you could magically remove all the Michael toxins
from your body, it still doesn't solve the problem
that the cells are still in rapid replication
because the damage was done.
But if you get rid of that, we know that your body is susceptible
to Michael toxins as a cause of cancer.
We don't want it to cause another cancer or cancer somewhere else.
So it's essential in my mind to find out what that causes
and deal with that.
And deal with other potential causes, other toxins,
other biotoxins.
That's why we do that testing.
We want to deal with all the comorbidities.
That's why I talked about autoimmune diseases
and deal with those comorbidities that
could be causes of cancer.
Secondly, a driver of cancer could be a term that we use
to what is fueling the cancer.
So remember, a cells that are in rapid replication
are very hungry.
So hungry cells need a fuel source.
That's why we take you off of certain things.
Dairy is a common fuel source.
That's why I recommend everybody with cancer
go on a lower sugar diet and keeping your glucose levels.
If you test them with a new cometer,
at a low range will also be helpful.
Does it mean everybody needs to go ketogenic?
Doesn't mean everybody needs to do anything specifically.
We want to test for what are fuel sources.
That can change.
So in cheek swab testing, if that changes,
I make that note and tell you,
stay off of this food too, you know,
change your diet, I make those changes.
So that's all done, that is all done on the cheek swab.
So if, you know, we always recheck that driver.
So you don't have to request that.
Okay, so you don't have to tell me, Patty,
I will just send you a question.
Originally, dairy was a driver.
The diets have no dairy.
This cheek swab dairy was not a drive, no.
So I don't rephrase it.
So if I say there's a different driver than, yes.
So if I don't tell you again that dairy is a driver
and I only make changes on the cheek swab.
So what I said, you back information on the cheek swab,
it's just that any changes, so stay is dairy free as possible.
But that brings up another question.
Can I ever just relax a bit on the driver?
The answer is always yes.
So if you've eliminated, you know,
a main fuel source for a period of time,
is it okay to have butter once in a while?
Or is it okay to put some cream in that coffee
a few times a week?
The answer is yes, always has been yes.
Because you can't, you're never going to completely
eliminate the fuel source.
So that's quite of a balance
that you're never going to be able to completely eliminate.
So and I also have always said, this is a diet.
It's not a dogma.
It's not a religion.
You're not, you know, first you're not
sitting by, you know, having some butter on your toast
or something like that.
So just make sure it end.
I will say also that it can be dangerous
to even have that thought in your mind
because that is producing anxiety
and what does anxiety do but stimulates
the authentic reaction which can be the worst thing
for your cancer.
And I've said over and over, you know, a hundred times
it's a lot of times the people that do the best
amounts of cancer and end up having the best success
and the people that are like, no, tell me what to do.
I'll do the best I can and I leave the results to go.
The ones that are frantic and anxious and worried
and concerned and analyzing everything and getting,
you know, having OCD issues about their cancer.
Again, the problem with that is it stimulates
glutamate, it stimulates sympathetic dominance.
It shuts down your immune system
and it shuts down your detoxification pathways.
All those things are not good.
So don't ever beat yourself up about, you know,
I don't know what goodness it was by, you know,
son's birthday or something and it'll hand a bite of cake.
Maybe let's all go to the cake, it's not a sin,
that's not how we're supposed to even act
with spiritual things, but only spiritual things.
It beats you well, but you make mistakes.
He mows you, shapes you, sometimes that's not pleasant,
but he's gentle and graceful and merciful
and that's the way you need to be
towards yourself when it comes to your balance.
All right, with that, we will say good night.
I hope you all have a wonderful night
and go do something fun and it's going to light out.
I'm gonna give you a light out, it's a good night.
All right, God bless you all, I'll be praying for you.
I'll be all, bye-bye.